the northwestern coastal town of
Blackpool has been having a makeover
with the help of the EU 14 million euros
of EU funding went into renovating its
trademarked our the EU gave 20 million
euros to build its new promenade and
improve sea defences without the EU
Blackpool would be in much worse shape
than it is now but that didn't stop
two-thirds of its residents from voting
to leave the European Union for we
should have got out years ago we were
conned into going into it we didn't sign
up for what we got I just think we
should be Britain and go back to being
British we were all right before 1972 I
think from we went in the euro so we
should be all right again as a resort
Blackpool has seen better days it's
still popular with day-trippers but
since the rise of the budget airlines
with their cheap and direct connection
to the sunshine revenues here have been
falling there's not much of black pools
former glory left now many hotels in the
city centre are empty even in the high
season many have had to close along with
local businesses hotel yay Gerard Walsh
blames the European banking crisis for
his hometowns demise I mean other
factors are the financial crash that the
country and fell into in recession and
therefore that the not kind of fat for
that was banks wouldn't lend to small
businesses such as myself they changed
their banking practices they removed
overdrafts for small businesses which a
lot of people unfortunately went into in
the winter months when the resort was
closed so the financial crash didn't
help also and that also saw a lack of
investment and people stayed away from
the town and so he voted brexit just
like his competitor down the road they
also cite another argument that held
sway during the referendum run-up
immigrations of major concern for me I
mean these people have travel into this
country to get jobs I mean this country
is being let down because of these zero
wanna come traction everywhere but home
grown Brits wouldn't even consider doing
many of the badly paid jobs in the hotel
business it's questionable whether
Britain can solve its social and
economic problems more easily outside
the EU brexit certainly won't make
Blackpool any more attractive